possiamo eliminare bianco vai purtroppo
dobbiamo dire la verità non impattare
con ruby storica stare di nuovo episodio
among abbiamo deciso di indossare i
nostri costumi da crew m impostori non
per noi non lo sappiamo giocheremo con
voi ma ci sarà una regola o molto molto
particolare
gli abbiamo chiesto come volete che
giochiamo con voi ad among us
consigliateci qualche modalità o qualche
trucchetto qualcosa di divertente avete
chiesto di giocare con voi ma con una
regola nemmeno è che non si può mentire
quindi tutti sono costretti a dire la
verità anche l'impostore quindi se
dovessimo sospettare qualcuno dei tour
impostori rispondere bisogna la verità e
lo stesso dobbiamo dire noi qui resto
per divertente sarà il cast è vero che
tutti rispetteranno le regole
volete vedere un altro episodio
dialogart davvero un bel mi piace a 10
mila mi piace fare un altro episodio
gameplay among us anzi consigliateci voi
le modalità sotto nei commenti occhetti
modalità insomma cateria dc tutte le più
belle andremo a farlo se non avete visto
il nuovo video in cui ci facciamo
discorsi facendo lievitare una nuova
guerra degli scherzi andate lo strappo
vederlo dopo questo video ma ora
mettetevi comodi prende di boccherini
siamo sino a che i ragazzi siamo tutti
qua abbiamo già scritto le regole pronti
a guardare separati ok allora musica
allora ricordiamoci che dobbiamo dire la
verità non possiamo smentire
assolutamente come mi ha rubato il
colore rosso e quindi sono blu purtroppo
il mio arancione orari scrivono si può
mentire
il rettore svizzero da iren elettrica io
ero con anita di tener quindi hanno
detto tutti la verità allora chi sarà
stato schifo che qualcuno ha votato nero
brano importo silenzioso
[Musica]
[Applauso]
lo store
abbiamo vinto la scorsa partita e non
abbiamo neanche dovuto dire la verità io
ero impostore ho vinto vitale ha perso
questa volta stiamo giocando assieme
perché server sono stato fuori o che si
parli io evitare siamo assieme di un
cagnolino
la regola è sempre la stessa non si può
mentire quindi troviamo sempre dire la
verità ma sarò abbastanza facile ora che
stiamo crew mail lo so ancora come ho
fatto ho visto nella sua parava forza
partita da impostore quando dovevo dire
la verità ma nessuno mi ha chiesto una
mia veste chiesta vita sei di un
impostore io avrei dovuto dire stesso
noi in realtà so che hanno già riparato
le luci ci sono tre in settori dobbiamo
stare molto attenti per vincere come
crew me se dobbiamo fare le giuste
domande
quindi direi che appena troviamo un
corpo chiediamo direttamente a quasi 18
l'impostore ottimo stato
vediamo chi lo ha riportato la riportato
blu puglia allora in elettrica crimi blu
state olimpo storie e dovrò per forza
rispondere la verità sono i rinnovi dei
signori
era vicino alla mente no no no e allora
blu non è l'impostore sicuramente perché
ha detto di no l'europa mentre e deve
dire la verità si risolviamo chi non sta
mentendo
ok allora schiviamo abbiamo subito il
raddoppio dell'inter e corri corri
vediamo chi sei quadri a chi non sta
salvando rota viola modo ciò che
arancione non è entrato qua ma l'idea la
prossima volta che c'è un emercency
bingo o troviamo un corpo dobbiamo
chiedere velocissimamente a tutti i
colori se sono loro gli impostori in
store
abbiamo pochissimi secondi chiediamo
primo arancione sito l'impostore giallo
facebook
beh qui nuovo signora forse riusciremo a
trovare no secondo me non è arancione
verona
ci sono tre impostori non ce la faremo
mai seguirsi arancio dopo che hanno
fatto questi di che non fa le faq poi
solo seguendo vuole eliminarsi non so
perché ma con la nostra tutta da giallo
stavolta dobbiamo essere più bravi nei
suoi le domande dobbiamo fare più
domande così loro dovevano dire la
verità troviamo gli impostori santhià
esatto posto andrà como dobbiamo stare
attenti noi a non farci fare troppe
domande perché lo siamo a dir la verità
elimina verde poi entra dentro il vento
[Musica]
che si prende vostro stack
dobbiamo stare attenti no non andare
vicino al corpo altrimenti si scoprono o
infatti infatti da tra l'altro non è che
si crea del corpo di verde che pure sa
che non lo troveranno mai verde perché
il nostro test edile poteri aspetta rosa
ok io che ho dato ok noi facciamo finta
di niente speriamo che nessuno ci farà
bene ma una domanda altrimenti dovremmo
dire la verità dove scrive rosa ma rosa
l'impostore il navigation
d'altro canto arancione
io non sono
e devi è passato il viola annate storage
quindi skip noti a tuoro che bello io mi
sono vista baciare ok nessuno sospetta
che un po tutti qualche mese fa forse se
lo facciamo questa volta allora vediamo
se ci segue qualcuno ce ne sono altre
impostarle si sta seguendo
qui c'è verde però attenzione ancora non
possiamo uccidere nessuno
no ma più ancora in pochi secondo
possiamo sabotare qualcosa bene un altro
importante ha portato qualcosa di più
mezzi così possiamo eliminare qualcuno
sa dove sono
scappa scappa scappa non se ne curano
bianco chi l'ha trovato rosa che è un
impostore la riporta paghiamo se dirà la
verità nei corridoi i corridoi di sé
rosa che è un impostore chi dicesse che
un'imposta vicino alla caffetteria ma
noi abbiamo l'abbiamo eliminata vicino
le comunicazioni e forse si è confuso
vicino ad aspettare abbiamo vinto
eccoci qua prossima partita
pronti vediamo cosa capite remo 21
impostare impostare i pastori
si no dobbiamo stare attenti perché
dobbiamo sempre dire la verità stiamo
attenti quindi i viola e bianco sono
impostori comando perché mi state
interpretate tutti di servizio a questo
marrone no non posso eliminare nessuno
perché mi fanno tutti quando totti
allontanato remo tre impostori brava
york mandiamo tutti in ambiti che
eravamo tutti eravamo tutti un posto
bellissimo questa sera è stato aspettano
che qualcuno bellissimo quando si lavora
così in squadra devo riportarlo
altrimenti sarò sospetta ovviamente farò
finta di niente basta qualcuno mi chiede
solo di un posto che dovrò dire di sì
devo dire la verità e ryan temersi
arancione salvo dice blog
io non l'ho visto dalle telecamere io
ero in elettrica dice bianco che è un
impostore
ma viola un altro impostore siccome
hanno fatto scoprirlo viola dicono mi
avete come viva
la vita bravi bravo violo perché ha
seguito le regole a detroit il problema
all'ala dove votare per forza altrimenti
poi sotto questo aspetto il problema è
che violano impostare quindi abbiamo
perso una di noi ha fatto che possiamo
farcela ancora ora sono tutti qua anche
bianchi impostare perché ora ha smesso
di funzionare a regime la prossima
partita è stata super divertente e
questo anche se mi dispiace per viola
che è stata costretta a dire che era un
impostore vediamo un bravo perché ha
seguito le regole viola di nuovo come
sia possibile bellissimi ea dire la
verità purtroppo dobbiamo dire la verità
è che gli elettori hanno votato tutti
noi noi scriviamo perché grande è anche
già beccato bravi tutti quanti sono
molto o che noi però possiamo rimanere
da fantasmi e bello anche fare la
partita da fare salto e quindi
osserviamo questa quota e vediamo
soprattutto se seguono le regole sempre
assai meno
proviamo guarda ma come ho fatto a
scomparire ma che strada di strada
vedendo un impulso verdetti verità che
adora anche devenuto
dove eravate dice rosa bravo rotta
perché si comandano tutti dire la verità
tutti devono dire dove erano stata una
domanda molto intelligenti infatti in
questo gioco per vincere bisogna fare al
sacco di domande devono dire la verità
dare nessuna scorso ciamo che lo chiamo
tutti quanti in caffetteria ho pagato
tutto il periodo sono gli impostori
dramma dai viola elimina qualcuno così
vincono gli impostori
ok possiedono da eliminare nzione di
orazioni è come un aspetto sarà il noce
non faccia un altro impostare quindi
siamo serata le domande a milano sta
giocando benissimo dai rosa devi
semplicemente chiedere era nero era
viola dai viola bravissimo ora viola
deve per forza dire che devo dare un
muro no non probabile bravo bravo bravo
viola capitolare
il gioco ha detto la verità mi sa che
gli impostori non vinceranno questa
volta la sassonero poi come crew match
ci sono ancora biancoblù è rotta
emergency meeting in un modo la sorgente
si aspetta di qualcuno allora se fa le
domande giuste riforme possono ancora
vincere basta chiedere prima uno poi
all'altro tale l'impostore blu sei tu
non so chi è ma voglio che giocani nero
nero invece furbissimo scritto mammamia
mancava un secondo per un secondo non ha
vinto perché hanno hanno riparato
dall'ossigeno blu ma blu dice la verità
e dice non sono io
hanno detto nero sei tu nero deve
rispondere deve rendere la verità nero
però purtroppo abbiamo versano in fondo
perché
i nomi che sono stati bravi molto questa
volta perché hanno chiesto le domande
giuste hanno giocato super bravissimi
carissimi che mezza di leo mi avete
eliminato quasi subito che ora facciamo
l'ultima partita abbiamo viviamo ultima
partita a data infatti ma per l'ultima
partita abbiamo pronti vediamo se saremo
ancora impostori si parte via
[Musica]
ok allora si aumenta storica siamo al
verde e rosa mutando nessun trucchetto
nota una moda nessun arc non so come sia
possibile abbiamo sempre un posto
comunque stiamo impostori assieme al
green cioè assieme a rosa ma stavolta
vinceranno gli impostori oicr europei
allora vediamo no siamo in troppi per
poter eliminare qualcuno era troppo
vicino
no sono tutti quanti stanno seguendo
così non possiamo eliminare nessuno ok
possiamo eliminare bianco vai o no
speriamo che non faccia allora di nuovo
dobbiamo dire la verità non ci riesce di
fama e ovviamente ci hanno votato tutti
anche gli impostori che ho fatto che
siamo di nuovo fantasmini vediamo se gli
altri impostori saremo bravi da riuscire
a cavarsela da soli così possiamo
chiudergli la porta qui nella elettrica
perché fa cercando di offrire ai limite
lo fa bruciare la forza chiusa ma ora a
ber di andrea riportarla ho trovato il
corpo ma l'ho trovato arancione strano
come noi verdi oscuro non l'ha riportata
chi riceve i greens pensi che sia scrive
viola
dovete essere più furbi dovete dire rosa
sei tu ne sei tu
avranno scappato hanno votato globale
perché non fanno bene bene casinò
importanti siamo in vantaggio vediamo
abbiamo un impostore dove è già sparito
il pastore qui alle camerin sta curando
le camere che elimina viola elimina
viola stanno per completare le parti
fiume si devono sbrigarsi lettori dai
sogni tutti dietro all'altro fare subito
gravi o no non ciò che sondato fare il
report
vediamo se fanno le giuste domande sei
tu arancione bravo nero che fai le
giuste domande o lo monta infatti ha
detto di no e del vero perché ha ragione
è un fiume
secondo me è rotta devi dire sei tu rota
quando sono rivista io stavano uscendo
rosa è vero
rose vede solo di impostare parte di
fatto hanno votato tutti rosa essere
anche fare la domanda quindi ci sono
arrivati da soli hanno visto uscire da
lì ci pensa che questa volta vincerà
amici si è rimasto solo un impostore
il grinch il verde ce la farà vediamo
proviamo ad aiutarlo e come info stole
che è andato alle camere per non destare
sospetto perché tutti quanti vanno alle
camere per controllare quindi due gialli
e li puoi eliminare se qualcuno deve
andare dai grigi poi anche sono state
sospetteranno non si muove ecco lo fanno
per finire le tasche sabotiamo
qualcos'altro no no stanno per vincere
il race man ha solo per discutere perché
non lo steccato termina volte capita
stima il verde se tali il countdown si
stoppa comunque adorando giocare con ali
emergency miti in pochi dicono non sono
io verde chiaro io non ho capito
comunque capito la prima volta che gioca
questo perde chiavi lynch ed è per
quello che voi non eliminava nessuno
dice io non solo ma l'hanno scoperto
le creme
grazie poi sono andati ci fanno troppo
divertente fare questo gioco in cui
tutti non potevo mentire sono di
località scriveteci nei commenti i
vostri consigli per il prossimo gameplay
qualche regola inventato ad hoc a sangue
ore super divertente si rivede
tralasciate bel mi piace e ora vediamo
quali sono i ciellini criticare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite una visione
ciao